Oh
a lot of people handle football before
it ever gets to the field they start
with cowhide footballs are traditionally
made of this leather because it wears
well over time with the done a worker
cuts out the four sections that make up
the fall skin a stamping machines and
brands of the skin with a company logo
they may put other markings elsewhere on
the ball depending on the design of the
model they're making to strengthen the
skin a seamstress says cotton in vinyl
linings onto all four sections then she
places them in a diet that positions
them for another set of markings now
it's time to sew the top sections
together and then the bottom ones to
each other exactly how many stitches
this next is this companies closely
guarded secret this press makes a hole
in one of the top sections for the air
better
to join the false top and bottom
sections the seamstress first post them
and then joins the edges together it's
important to flatten the four seams to
do this the work replaces each one on a
wheel as a roller passes over the top a
15-second steam softens the leather and
makes it easier to manipulate a concave
press flattens the seams at the tips
this will also keep the ball smooth when
they inflated the worker places about a
metal ball then reaching through the
opening between the lace holes he grabs
the other side of the skin and feeds it
through
the bladders made of polyurethane a type
of plastic with a vinyl patch
reinforcing the lacing air she inflates
the bladder a bit make it rigid enough
for lacing
after steadying the ball with plants she
uses an awl to thread the lace through
the holes just one final race measuring
four feet it worms through both sides
and then down the center and through all
the holes once again next workers
temporarily over inflate the balls
steel bolts around them to ensure though
assume the correct shape after 90
seconds the extra air seeps out
finally a factory inspects the balls to
ensure they're up to standard fully
inflated a ball must weigh no more than
fifteen ounces it should measure 21 and
a half inch
through the middle and 28 inches around
both ends after a five-day manufacturing
process these balls are ready for the
field